when you walk into an audition what are
you telling yourself even if you think I
have this idea about who this character
is and I don't think I'm gonna get it
but I'm this still I'm gonna still show
up and try to do what I can
what do I tell myself what do you do are
you giving yourself any kind of a talk
or no each each situation is totally
different
I don't think for me it talks really
help in that instance you know if I have
an audition that day you're thinking
okay especially if it's at 5:00 p.m.
which I hate the auditions because you
have to hold on to that all day drives
me crazy I like a good early audition in
the morning let's get it done
no because it's tough you got to hang on
to that all day
I think preparation is is key you know a
talk for me won't do me because I'm so
nervous and I'm like oh shut up Chad I
don't want to hear your oh just
go in and do it and I think you just got
to go in there and do it you got to be
prepared I you know I like to if I'll
have my sides here I will I will
memorize the whole entire thing
especially if it's like the next day and
one thing I do to sort of help that
actor is pay attention it's really a
great thing every phone now has a voice
recorder right so I will go and I'll
take the sides and I'll read every line
even if it's not my line I will read the
entire scene out loud at a very monotone
voice and then I'll replay that over and
over and over again and you go in the
next day and I'll be memorized so I
think preparation will take away sort of
any anxiety that you had well you should
be anxious and nervous but it's going to
take away that that extra moment of fear
because look we've all actors as some of
some sometimes we don't prepare as much
as we should and we've gone in we've all
been there we've all been there and um
you know you you you get cold honey you
know you go in there and you've been
doing your thing and you loose your
place and you've got to go back and it's
awful you know your your face turns red
and it's late
and you know that instance you're like
I'm not getting this this just went out
the door so you got to be prepared and
it's tough to do because sometimes
you'll get an audition for the next day
and you'll get another one and you get
another one you've got three the next
day and they're all 15 pages long and
they want to see you be seen so you know
you gotta you gotta be willing to do
that work
you